time then for the press preview a first
look at saturday's front pages tonight
i'll check out the headlines with the
director of the demos think tank polly
mckenzie and the pr
consultant alex deans speaking to them
shortly first of all let's take a look
at
what is on some of those front pages
starting with the mail well they're
positively furious aren't they the duke
and duchess of sussex
departure from their remaining royal
duties and titles while prince philip is
in hospital
asking have they no respect well the
couple appeared to contradict
buckingham palace's assertion that they
wouldn't be doing any more public
service work that's according to the
times
the mirror says the queen says she felt
she had no choice but to take the
decision
the express describes her majesty as
resolute
but sad while the star dismissively bids
the
couple doodle pip the eye previews
monday's announcement of the lockdown
relaxation roadmap
the paper says people will be allowed to
meet one friend or extended family
member in parks from
next month it's also a big story for the
telegraph which mentions two households
being able to meet outdoors by easter
at the beginning of april the guardian
understands the prime minister and his
chief medical officer professor chris
witte are at loggerheads over how many
children
should be allowed back to school at once
and the financial times reports on the
supreme court's ruling that uber drivers
should be legally classified as
workers meaning they're entitled to
rights
such as the minimum wage and holiday
i'm joined by polly mckenzie and alex
dean great to see you on this friday
evening there's the cat as well
always good to see the cat making an
appearance polly um
in fact why don't we start with you
polly because then we get to see more of
the cat
um front page of the eye
we're not going to talk about the royals
just yet let's stick with coronavirus
much anticipated of course
by humans and animals potentially uh
boris johnson's uh address to the nation
on monday
he says it's all about data not dates
the data is looking remarkably good uh
the eye is saying that meet friend or
family outdoors next month
i mean it's not great is it if that if
that's going to be the headline
we can meet a friend or a family member
in a park next month but i guess it's
better than nothing polly
i think it's a very large amount better
than nothing it's
it's good positive news it's going in
the right direction
and you know i know what day is it it's
not that long until next month
uh and i'm really really excited about
being able to meet friends and family
members outside
being able to um there's talk in the
papers as well about opening up
care homes for proper visits where
you'll be able to
hold the hand of your loved one and i
think that is so
important it's so important after this
incredibly grueling lockdown period that
people
have that feeling that it's coming to an
end that they can hold out hope
and so i i think that actually this year
in comparison to last year
the government's done quite a good job
of not
over promising only to under deliver
they learned the lesson from christmas
mocking everyone who said we might have
to cancel christmas and then cancelling
christmas
this time they are being cautious
they're not over promising
but they are offering us some light at
the end of the tunnel and you know
for me and the cat we really we want to
get out of here
yeah i'm uh here here um alex uh i mean
the eye
is saying the pm plans to let people
socialize with a friend or member of
extended family in parks from march now
at the moment
you are allowed to meet one other person
for exercise
in a park so so how different is this i
mean is there an argument that the
government
is going to be overly cautious no i
think it's that you don't have to
pretend to be doing star jumps anymore
say hello to a friend look i think this
is really good
and encouraging news and we always knew
that uh the unlocking was going to be
gradual
and you know any sign of the next phase
is good and let's be clear
my fear was that we were going to go
further into lockdown
there's always been a reason to you know
things have always been a bit worse than
we'd expected there's always been
another variance or another thing
happening or a red list or something
that meant
that hope was a little bit further away
on the horizon
so i think thank goodness that we're
finally going to come out lockdown
let's embrace this and let's respect the
fact that government is taking us
through this carefully
rather than as polly says over-promising
and then not being able to deliver on it
yeah boris johnson of course has had his
fingers burned already um hasn't he
i'm alex just staying with you um
there's been a lot of talk today about
tony blair's
idea for this sort of traffic light
system i mean you're rolling your eyes
but uh he's been right before hasn't he
he came up with that
idea of having the the spacing between
the jabs a long time before
it became government policy perhaps he's
going to be right this time as well
yeah i don't know i'm pretty sure he
didn't come up with the idea he
certainly has publicly associated
that idea but i do wonder when tony
blair will finally understand
that him being attacked attached to any
form of public policy
makes that policy less popular and less
likely to be implemented
rather than more the man is in the
truest sense
toxic to any set any form of political
discourse he should if he wants to help
something
not talk about it polly
i i certainly true that tony blair
didn't invent traffic lights
but um we already had tiered systems we
had a tiered system for schools that was
implemented and then got rid of or never
quite rolled out we had
the uh some sort of biosecurity regime
over the summer
then we had the geographical tears so it
to me it's just another
labeling system which in the end will be
uh
sort of suddenly become outdated three
weeks three months later
and and in the end it just adds
confusion i think it's actually much
simpler
if we have uh just follow
the rules everybody has the same set of
rules
and we come out of this together and
trying to suggest that there
are tiers and that you don't have to
make adjustments kind of subtly as you
follow the data
it's it's just kind of ridiculous really
so i think we should give up on traffic
light systems
okay let's move on then and uh talk
about schools front page of the guardian
witty and pm clash over big bang
return to school march the 8th is when
children will go back to the classroom
but we wait to see don't we whether it's
all children in all schools
or whether it's going to be a staggered
return
and clearly those discussions perhaps
still going on alex
yeah and on monday we're going to have
an announcement from the prime minister
about the the root map for unlocking and
the question of what happens with
schools is a big part of that
there is a live discussion and a topic
that we've
played out over the months in the course
of these reviews about the extent to
which it's good to hear
differing opinions and the extent which
is good to hear people of having
different perspectives
and on the one hand people are treating
us like adults if they
are willing to let us know there's more
than one opinion about something there
are topics about
which reasonable people can reasonably
disagree and on the other hand there's
the potential for people to become
confused when they have in this example
apparent political voice going in one
direction and apparently the scientific
voice going in another
and i think it's probably a bit
unhelpful for worried parents and indeed
worried teachers
to have that lack of clarity i
understand that people don't want to be
associated
with a course being set out with which
they do not agree
but in the end there's a reason i know
it's different but it's not that
different
there's a reason that we came up with
the notion of collective cabinet
responsibility
and that once you're on a path you take
that direction and everyone
supports it because it's important that
we have clarity surely in a pandemic
it's more important than ever
that we have clarity about what the
rules are i mean teachers polly
have said that there hasn't been enough
clarity and they're really concerned
because they say that they need time to
organize whatever it is that the
government wants them to put in place
this idea of testing for example is is
one such
issue that they've got we had a complete
nightmare
over christmas where schools were told
basically on the last day of turn that
they were going to have to reopen
at the beginning of the following term
meaning that teachers had to spend their
christmas holidays planning for
mass testing regimes then they were
opened for one
day with some schools asked never to
open
and then close down again at the end of
the first day of term
so teachers have absolutely been kind of
marched up the hill and back down again
about 17 times
i'm not surprised that they're exhausted
but alex is right they're having
clarity and march the eights is still a
few weeks away
it's a much better kind of planning
window i think what we
should see is a bit more flexibility for
schools who know
they know the grounds they know the
buildings they know the parents
to manage that entryway over the first
couple of weeks and stagger things
if they think that that's best for them
to to build up parent confidence to
to put in testing whatever it might be i
think again the difficulty we had at the
end of
last year was when uh gavin williamson
the education secretary for example
kind of threatening legal action against
local authorities that were
wanting to close just a few days early
before the end of term
and the reality is if we don't get it
right you do then sometimes get
infection that that breaks out in a
school and then you have to close down
the bubbles or
half the teachers have gone off on sick
to self-isolate
and so actually you end up with more
learning loss that way
than if you just take it a bit slow and
give teachers a bit more autonomy
especially those head teachers to plan
for their local circumstances yeah give
them more responsibility i mean
they they know their school and their
their people's best of course um and
let's just finish this
half uh alex with a story that's in the
times
um i mean we're learning more and more
aren't we about long covid
and this study is is quite concerning
yeah it's concerning because there is
naturally a belief that
um you know we can get vaccinated and
get over this and secondly
that um if you've had clovid and you've
recovered then you know life goes on
back to normal
as if you've had the flu increasingly it
seems that's not the case and the
important thing coming out of this study
in the times is
it's not the case for really quite young
people as well
many have claimed that the threat from
coronavirus being exaggerated and i know
that we'll be pouring over
that in inquiry after inquiry and so
forth for years to come
but it does seem from this study that
there is a significant risk the younger
people from so-called long covid
that is significant life impairing
conditions well after
the time that you first contracted the
rotavirus and that should be concerning
to us all
yeah another reason why uh we need to uh
take it slow and steady perhaps coming
out of lockdown um alex polly thank you
both very much for
the moment coming up well the mail is
very angry at the duke and duchess of
sussex
again we'll have more on that when we
come back
you're watching part 2 of the press
preview polly and alex still with me
uh ft polly and this uber story has been
interesting hasn't it uh
the landmark uk ruling which is going to
have ramifications really
around the world and it seems that
drivers potentially
are split on it
yeah so this is quite a narrow case
actually
around the employment status of workers
several you know several years ago
actually
about 16 workers a test case um that
said basically they should be classified
as
as workers rather than as uh
self-employed people
and that changes their entitlement to uh
to
things like uh sip pay or holiday pay
but crucially means that they ought to
be paid for time they're spending on the
app
i think the key rather than time that
actually spent driving as it were
the key question is because uber have
made some changes
over the following years to the exact
model and exactly how
the um how the system works
is that there may need to be further
test cases and
to push the boundary of this my own view
is that we need to
take a different view of how we regulate
this gig economy and that you do need to
have
a kind of minimum wage for
self-employment and the uber thing is
really only the tip of the iceberg
because actually some of the people who
are paid
the worst are delivery drivers doing uh
self-employment with their own vans for
example or cleaners who are forced to
actually pay compensation if they uh
don't turn up for a contract because of
the self-employment
terms so i actually think this is just
the tip of the iceberg and we need a
kind of
much more comprehensive review of how we
deal with employment
and disguised employment effectively
right at the bottom of the list yeah
it's interesting um alex that polly
mentions the start of this case in 2016
because uber has changed massively but
not even
only that there are loads of competitors
now and i know when i've got into an
uber before they're using
lots of different apps for lots of
different firms you know they're not
just
using uber they're on bolt or captain or
whatever they're called so it's a very
different
outfit now to the one it was well
that flexibility is right and the
ability of drivers to switch from one
app to another
whether they be delivering something or
driving people
is i think part of the appeal and indeed
it's part of the
competition between those providers for
drivers um
but let's be clear you should never be
worse off in employment
than you are not in employment and if
the state has to have a flexible system
that says
okay you made this much um from driving
at this month or this year
um there before the state contributes
this much then we should have a system
that does that to ensure that there is a
level below which nobody falls
but if we are really saying that people
that these systems the gay economy
is going to be harmed in a way that says
you are or employees even if you only
drive an uber
for argument's sake for to take it to an
extreme one hour a year
or you only drive an uber 10 percent of
the time you're doing other things in
that time
then it's going to significantly harm
the gig economy that we all benefit from
so it seems to me that whilst we've had
judgment in this case today
the issue is by no means finish okay and
uh we haven't got much time left to talk
about the big split
polly not kim and kanye but the sussexes
and uh the royal family the firm the
mail says have they
no respect what do you think
well as usual lots of the papers are
full of a probium for this
uh slightly tedious pair of wellness
podcasters
as they go off just about platitudes on
netflix personally i'm just
i'm just bored by them i just i'm not
offended by them
mediocre royals are nothing new there's
been plenty of mediocre royals before
and i i just i the outrage is
totally out of proportion to anything
they do and of course
there is some misogyny there there's
racism there all sorts of stuff but
frankly we'd all just be better off if
we stopped paying any attention to them
alex let's be clear about what the mail
is incentive about it's not just that
they've taken this position and they
want to
not return to be working royals which is
of course their right and good luck
i think that they're upset because
there's been an exchange of press
releases which you might think is a
funny way to live a private life
chunning the limelight
they're upset because in exchange of
press releases when the the sussex is
effectively pushed back and said
you don't care what you say about
service is universal which is of course
true
but you know we'll carry on serving
anyway he's sort of thumbing a nose of
your family
and that's what they're upset about in
these circumstances when prince philip
is apparently
uh rather unwell rather than the
decision of the sussex retreat from
private football they have
many retreat from royal duties per se uh
and if the male
were getting that upset about the basic
decision then i think they
wouldn't have a point but as it is i
kind of think they do okay
alex polly thank you we shall speak to
you again in half an hour so